[Music]  what's your favorite part about being in  love every day is like super exciting  just like waking up and be like oh yeah  ariana grande has a new man a source  tells ET the 24 year old singer is  casually dating SNL funny man Pete  Davidson  they added quote ariana is in a very  good place and very happy right now want  to smoke some pot or something let's  smoke some crack man Pete and Ari  creatively teamed up for that bit when  ariana hosted SNL in March 2016 fast  forward to made 2018 a source spotted  the pair hanging together at an SNL  afterparty  [Music]  earlier this month Ari confirmed her  split from boyfriend Mac Miller the pair  dated for nearly two years our source  adds the former couple had been on the  rocks for a while they split after the  Coachella Music Festival last month  [Music]